the tradition of the Academy has been at
last year's male winner presents the
Oscar to this year's female winner for
reasons beyond our control that is not
possible tonight so speaking for myself
I confess that I cannot say that a
Matisse is better than a Picasso but
this I do know
they are both products of struggle
training and above all very special
gifts and so it is with the players
nominated tonight I read that line wrong
and so it is with the players nominated
tonight
the best performance by an actress the
nominees are
Janet Sussman for Nicholas and Alexandra
a horizon pictures production Columbia
Julie Christie from McCabe and mrs.
Miller the Robert Altman David Foster
production Warner Brothers Jane Fonda
for Clute a Gus production Warner
Brothers Glenda Jackson for Sunday
Bloody Sunday a Joseph Janney production
United Artists Vanessa Redgrave the Mary
Queen of Scots Hal Wallis Universal
Pictures limited production may I have
the envelope please
the winner is Jane Fonda
thank you thank you very much members of
the Academy and thank all of you who
were plotted there's a great deal to say
and I'm not going to say it tonight I
would just like to really thank you very
much